hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live immer mehr Menschen werden über die
polnische und tschechische Grenze nach
Deutschland geschleust es ist ein
gefährliches Geschäft mit Menschenleben
eingepfercht in Transporter häufig ohne
Nahrung oder Wasser tagelang unterwegs
die Bundesregierung lehnt eine
Verschärfung von Grenzkontrollen ab
trotz steigender Zahlen Behörden vor Ort
an den Ländern in den Bundesländern die
es betrifft so Sachsen die sprechen von
einer großen Belastung und Sachsen hat
entschieden schickt nun seine eigene
Polizei an die Grenze es heißt die Zahl
der Schleusung hat in den letzten Wochen
derart zugenommen dass wir uns jetzt zum
Handeln gezwungen sehen das sagt Armin
Schuster er ist der CDU Innenminister in
Sachsen und hat sich heute morgen auch
noch mit folgendem im ARD Morgenmagazin
geäußert
das ist das letzte Mittel das ist
natürlich ein Beleg dafür dass Schengen
einfach nicht funktioniert aber wenn wir
Beschlüsse nicht umsetzen wie sie
beispielsweise im Februar März gefasst
wurden wenn Deutschland nicht Vorreiter
ist mein Ausbau der Schengen Außengrenze
und auch der Sicherheit wenn wir da
nicht Druck ausüben dann sind wir eben
die hauptbelasteten und dann kann ich
nicht mehr anders als zu dem ultima
ratio greifen
Grenzkontrollen oder zumindest
Schleierfahndung
deshalb ist unser Thema heute wie
Schleuser für mehr illegale Migration in
Sachsen sorgen versagt der Rechtsstaat
und unser erster Gast ist auch schon zu
sehen er ist heute bei uns wir können
sprechen zuerst mit Heiko teggerts
Vorsitzender der Bundespolizei
Gewerkschaft der jetzt heute Abend bei
uns ist hallo schön guten Abend guten
Abend
ihr könnt Herr tegart natürlich Fragen
stellen per Mail oder direkt im Stream
mit kommentieren macht das gerne es ist
Zeit für eure Fragen ab jetzt eine halbe
Stunde der Tag hat schildern Sie uns
vielleicht gerne zunächst mal die
Aufgabe der Bundespolizei an der Grenze
was dürfen sie was dürfen sie nicht was
passiert da also die Bundespolizei hat
gerade gesetzt die Aufgabe die Grenzen
um Deutschland herum und auf den
Flughäfen in Deutschland zu überwachen
das heißt wir kontrollieren
stichprobenartig ob Menschen die zu uns
kommen die Einreise Voraussetzungen
erfüllen sprich
die identitätsdokumente bei sich haben
Reisepässe gegebenenfalls bei sich haben
und sich Vermerke unter Umständen also
Visa in den Reisepässen drinne haben das
ist die ureigenste Aufgabe des damaligen
Bundesgrenzschutzes und der heutigen
Bundespolizei also sie kontrollieren
stichprobenartig sind aber eben keine
Grenzbehörde sie dürfen keine
grenzpolitischen Maßnahmen vornehmen was
heißt das dann genau in der Praxis und
was führt dazu jetzt ihrer Meinung nach
auch eben zu einem Problem richtig also
die Bundespolizei ist Grenzbehörde an
zugelassenen Grenzübergang Stellen mit
dem Beitritt der meisten Staaten in
Europa zum schengender Übereinkommen zum
schengender durchführungsübereinkommen
hat die Bundespolizei derzeit die
Grenzübergangsstellen in der Regel auf
den Flughäfen und auf den See Häfen mit
einer Ausnahme das ist die
österreichische Grenze die wurde
2015 sozusagen notifiziert also
Grenzübergangsstellen festgelegt dort
ist die Bundespolizei Grenzbehörde wenn
die Bundespolizei Grenzbehörde ist dann
darf die Bundespolizei auch polizeiliche
Maßnahmen nach dem Aufenthaltsgesetz
treffen sprich an den Grenzen
zurückweisen oder zurückschieben in die
Nachbarstaaten diese Grenzbehörde sind
wir nicht an den Grenzen wo eben keine
Grenzübergänge notifiziert worden sind
sprich bei der Europäischen Union
angemeldet worden sind und das sind die
Grenzen beispielsweise nach Polen und
nach Tschechien und an diesen Grenzen
eben soll die Situation jetzt ganz
aktuell in den letzten Wochen auch schon
eben sich immer mehr verschärfen unsere
Reporterin Anja Chalet die waren
Hirschfelder im Landkreis Görlitz in
Sachsen unterwegs in einer sogenannten
bearbeitungsstraße wo geflüchtete
hingebracht werden nachdem sie eben
aufgefasst worden sind und ein kurzer
Eindruck von der Situation vor Ort den
schauen wir uns jetzt gemeinsam an
hier reicht die Tafel für die Anzahl der
Flüchtlinge die an einem Tag registriert
werden nicht mehr aus sodass sie auf den
Fliesen im Gang weiterschreiben müssen
hier wird im Stationsbetrieb werden die
erfass die werden registriert es werden
die Personalien festgestellt es wird zum
Beispiel hier in dem Raum hinterher
kennen uns diese Behandlung durchgeführt
das heißt wir werden Fingerabdrücke
genommen die werden überprüft in den
Datenbank ob die Person denn schon
irgendwo eingeladen begangen hat oder
vielleicht in einer anderen europäischen
asylvanten kann der illegale
Grenzübertritt ist eine Straftat die
Männer die sich hier von den Strapazen
ihrer Flucht ausruhen werden
schnellstmöglich in eine ernstaufnahme
gebracht auf so viele geflüchtete jeden
Tag sind sie hier nicht eingestellt die
Kapazitäten reichen einfach nicht
die Kapazitäten reichen nicht hören wir
was ist das was sie aktuell besonders
kritisieren und auch das was sie eben
dann natürlich im Umkehrschluss auch
fordern
richtig also ich kritisiere aber schon
seit längerem seit fast einem Jahr dass
eben die Kapazitäten der Bundespolizei
dort vor Ort insbesondere in dem Bereich
im Görlitz rum das sind die beiden
Bundespolizeiinspektion Ludwigsdorf und
Ebersbach hauptsächlich dass dort
schlichtweg viel zu wenig Personal vor
Ort ist um diesen riesigen Grenzraum den
die Bundespolizei dort zu überwachen hat
überhaupt noch stimmt zu können
dankenswerter Weise das muss man
wirklich so sagen unterstützt ja die
sächsische Polizei derzeit die
Bundespolizei dort in der
Grenzüberwachung viel einfacher wäre es
aber man würde den Reiseverkehr aus
Polen und Tschechien kanalisieren an
bestimmte
Grenzübergangsstellen verlagern dann
bräuchte man deutlich weniger Personal
Bundespolizei seitlich als jetzt
Überwachung eines grenzraums und man
hätte eine viel höhere Kontrolldichte
und würde damit den Schlepperbanden das
Leben schwer machen spricht
das Risiko erhöhen erwischt zu werden
denn das Einschleusen von Ausländern das
ist eine schwerwiegende Straftat und
alle andere Regel verhängen die
Staatsanwaltschaften dort unten in dem
Landkreis dann auch Untersuchungshaft
gegen die Schleuser und harte
Haftstrafen wer sind denn eigentlich
ganz konkret die Schleuser die sie
aufgreifen vorfinden wer sind die
Schleuser und vor allem auch warum
steigen die Zahlen jetzt gerade so sehr
also die Schleuser das können wir
beobachten sind vorrangig Osteuropäer
also
Polen Tschechien auch Ukraine dabei
Slowaken also alle alle Staaten die so
entlang der Schleuser Routen liegen wir
haben dort unten das Phänomen dass dort
zwei
schleuserrouten aufeinander treffen das
eine ist die derzeit verschobene
Balkanroute also alles das was von von
Griechenland dann über den Balkan nach
Nordwest Europa kommt und das was über
die sogenannte Ostroute kommt also über
Moskau Belarus sozusagen über Polen dann
nach Deutschland die treffen dort
zusammen und deshalb häuft sich das da
ein weiteres Phänomen ähm was immer
dafür sorgt dass die Zahlen auch in den
vergangenen Jahren im Herbst ansteigen
sind Erkenntnisse die wir gewonnen haben
dass viele Menschen die bereits im
Frühjahr unerlaubt nach Europa
eingereist sind in Griechenland und in
Italien in die illegale Beschäftigung
gehen also als Erntehelfer dort
fungieren und dann sich jetzt zum Herbst
also zum Ende der Erntezeit dann
weitermachen auf dem Weg Richtung Norden
und das ist eben das Indiz dafür das
bekanntermaßen ab September extrem
ein extrem hoher Anstieg der
Feststellung der Bundespolizei an diesen
Grenzen stattfindet in den letzten
Jahren
Innenministerin Faser von der SPD die
bleibt bislang bei ihrem klaren Nein zu
fest stationierten Grenzkontrollen an
der beispielsweise deutsch-polnischen
Grenze eben im Innenministerium hatten
wir für ein Interview angefragt da
konnte man heute uns leider mit einem
Jawort Interview nicht aushelfen
antwortete aber schriftlich wir schauen
da mal kurz zusammen rein was die
Antwort war
die vorübergehende Wiedereinführung von
binnen Grenzkontrollen richtet sich nach
den Vorgaben der Verordnung EU 2016 399
Schengener grenzkodex und kommt nur als
letztes Mittel Ultima Ratio und Betracht
außerdem ist zu berücksichtigen wie
schwerwiegen stationäre Grenzkontrollen
den täglichen Pendelverkehr von
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
Gewerbetreibenden und Unternehmen
beeinträchtigen
also Grenzkontrollen nur als ultima
ratio so heißt es und außerdem bekamen
wir auch noch in der Mail folgendes zu
lesen der Bund beobachtet die
Entwicklung an den Grenzen weiter
entsorgfältig so sagte das
Innenministerium und geht weiterhin im
Dialog mit den Ländern und den
Betroffenen Nachbarstaaten Lage
angepasst vor so schrieben sie noch okay
Lage angepasst wie würden Sie denn jetzt
die Lage beschreiben und warum sind Sie
auch der Meinung dass sie die Lage
verbessern können also wenn frau
Ministerin Phaser tatsächlich Lage
angepasst agieren möchte und ihre
Entscheidung zur Einführung von
stationären ganz Kontrollen Lage
abhängig machen möchte dann braucht man
ja keine Glaskugel sondern sich einfach
nur mal die harten Fakten anschauen die
Zahlen an der österreichischen Grenze
sind derzeit weit unter den Zahlen an
der sächsischen Grenze beispielsweise
und deshalb ist für mich überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehbar warum der
österreichischen Grenze die stationären
Grenzkontrollen die seit 2015 bestehen
jetzt auch weiter verlängert worden sind
durch Frau Faser nämlich genau
offensichtlicher vor dem aufgrund des
schengender grenzkodex und an den
Grenzen zur Tschechischen Republik und
zu Polen eben nicht also es ist weder
für mich noch für meine Kolleginnen und
Kollegen nachvollziehbar
darüber hinaus ich habe es vorhin schon
mal gesagt hat die Bundespolizei zur
Verstärkung dieser
Bundespolizeiinspektion in Ludwigsdorf
und Ebersbach nur mal als Beispiel fast
zehn Einsatzhundertschaften
bundesbereitschaftspolizei rund um die
Uhr im Einsatz das heißt meine
Kolleginnen und Kollegen kommen seit
Wochen und Monaten schon nicht mehr aus
den Stiefeln die gehen dort in neun Tage
Einsätze oder länger und sind dann ein
paar Tage mal wieder zu Hause und gehen
dann in den nächsten grenzeinsatz die
Befürchtung die Frau Ministerin
offensichtlich hat dass es dazu
Beeinträchtigung des Verkehrs kommt und
dass der der Pendler auch das kann ich
nicht bestätigen und da sollte sich das
Bundesinnenministerium mal ganz intensiv
die Professionalität der Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Bundespolizei an der
österreichischen Grenze anschauen wie
gesagt seit 2015 führen wir dort die
sogenannten stationären ganz Kontrollen
durch und jeder auch schon mal nach
Österreich oder Italien in den Urlaub
gefahren ist der wird feststellen dass
er da an der Grenze nicht länger als 10
oder 15 Minuten steht also hoch
professionell gegen meine Kollegen vor
und ziehen ja auch nicht jedes Auto raus
sondern wir haben ja polizeiliche
Lagebilder die uns sagen beispielsweise
in einem kleinen Transporter könnten
Menschen eingefärbt in Lebensgefahr auf
der Ladefläche sitzen die werden dann
rausgezogen und kontrolliert also auch
da hängt der Vergleich so ein bisschen
mich enttäuscht dass ehrlich gesagt das
so leichtfertig mit dieser kostbaren mit
mit diesem kostbaren Produkt
Bundespolizei vor Ort umgegangen wird
aber wie lange sollte denn dann ihrer
Meinung nach so einem Maßnahme dann in
Sachsen von stationären Grenzkontrollen
andauern wann entscheidet man denn auf
sowas auch wieder dann zu Ende sein soll
ja also solche Maßnahmen dauern so lange
wie sie dauern müssen ähm also herr
Schuster hat das ja vorhin in seinem
Beitrag ganz eindrucksvoll geschildert
irgendwie scheint ja schenke nicht zu
funktionieren denn wir müssen uns vor
Augen führen normalerweise dürften ja an
diesem Binnengrenzen überhaupt gar keine
müssen zu uns kommen die nicht schon
irgendwo in einem anderen europäischen
Staat registriert sind weil viele die
gerade über die Balkanroute einreisen
sind durch vier Schengen Vertragsstaaten
gereist offensichtlich ohne Kontrolle
und genau da liegt ja der Hase im
Pfeffer
führt man diese stationären
ganzkontrollen ein signalisiert man
natürlich auch an die anderen klingen
Vertragspartner Leute schaut mal in die
Statuten und haltet euch bitte an die
Verträge nur wer sich an die Verträge
hält kann auch davon zehren dass wir in
Europa an der Reisefreiheit festhalten
können also insofern dauern solche
stationären Grenzkontrollen so lange bis
die Zahlen dann wieder runtergehen und
die Lage wieder wieder zu dem normalen
Betrieb zurückzukehren lässt und sie
glauben auch dass das die richtige
Maßnahme wäre um die Zahlen runter zu
bekommen denn es gibt ja auch andere
Nachbarländer die wir haben die also
diese stationären Grenzkontrollen
eingeführt haben wo die Zahlen das jetzt
nicht unbedingt widerspiegeln schauen
Sie nach Frankreich frankreich hat links
um seit dem ersten Mai glaube ich dieses
Jahr sogenannte Grenzkontrollen
eingeführt und mit großem Erfolg also
die Zahlen in Frankreich sind
zurückgegangen auch Österreich
verzeichnet Seite Einführung der
stationären ganz Kontrollen nach
Slowenien und nach
Ungarn meine ich ein Rückgang von knapp
17 % der Migration also das zeigt schon
Wirkung diese Maßnahmen natürlich immer
als ultima ratio aber wenn nicht jetzt
das ultima ratio erreicht ist wann denn
dann also wie lange wollen wir denn noch
warten schaut man sich auch mal oder
vergleicht man die Feststellung der
Bundespolizei an der Grenze mal mit den
Zahlen des Bundesamt für Migration und
Flüchtlinge was ja auch monatliche
Statistiken macht da kann man sagen mit
den Juli Zahlen liegen die die die
erstantragsasystellung beim Bundesamt
bei ungefähr 188.000 die Bundespolizei
hat um die 10.000 festgestellt dass zeig
wie hoch die Dunkelziffer ist und wie
das Geschäft der Schlepperbanden nach
wie vor blüht also wenn man jetzt nicht
eindeutig ein Signal setzt wir machen
euch es schwer und kontrolliert nach
Deutschland einzureisen dann brauche ich
den Kampf gegen die Schlepperbanden auch
nicht wirklich aufnehmen zum Schluss
noch eine Frage aus dem Stream an sie
die ich gesehen hatte die mir
aufgefallen war da fragte sich jemand
was kann die Politik tun um die Arbeit
der Grenzpolizei zu erleichtern die
Politik kann die Bundespolizei an der
binnengrenze zur Grenzbehörde machen
damit die Bundespolizei dort
polizeiliche Maßnahmen treffen kann
nämlich zurückweisen kann jetzt nicht
jeden aber zumindestens diejenigen die
keine Bleibeperspektive in Deutschland
haben das Sprechen nur von denjenigen
die mit einer wieder einreisesperregel
belegt sind weil sie schon mal
abgeschoben worden sind oder diejenigen
die in einem anderen europäischen Staat
schon Schutz gefunden haben der darüber
sprechen wir ja ähm momentan leiten
meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen auch
diese Menschen an die
landesaufnahmeeinrichtung weiter und in
einem langwierigen Verfahren stellt das
Bundesamt dann fest dass keine
Bleibeperspektive vorhanden ist also im
Prinzip genau das was meine Kollegen an
der Grenze schon festgestellt haben und
dort wird dann über Umwege mit einem
riesen Zeitverzug eine Rückführung
durchgeführt das kann man sich sparen
und das würde nicht nur uns die Arbeit
erleichtern sondern auch ein fairer
Umgang sein mit all denjenigen die
versuchen hier nach Europa und
Deutschland zu kommen sagt Heiko Tag als
er ist der Vorsitzende der
bundespolizeigewerkschaft vielen Dank
für Ihre Zeit heute Abend sehr gerne
und wir können jetzt sprechen mit
unserem nächsten Gesprächspartner bei
mir ist Migrationsforscher Gerald Knaus
erst der Vorsitzende der Denkfabrik
europäische stabilitätsinitiative und
kann mit uns jetzt auch politisches
Handeln hier in Deutschland aber eben
auch politisches Handeln oder nicht
handeln in Europa einschätzen schön dass
Sie bei uns in Technos schönen guten
Abend sie haben eben gerade zugehört und
wir haben vor allem eben gerade auch
schon einmal angesprochen die Lage zum
Beispiel an der Grenze zu Österreich
dort werden eben unsererseits stationäre
Grenzkontrollen durchgeführt begründet
wird das von der Innenministerin Fräser
mit den engen Beziehungen zwischen
Deutschland und Polen also das nimmt sie
als Begründung warum es dort nicht
stattfindet sie sagt die engen Beziehung
zwischen Deutschland und Polen im
alltäglichen Leben die würden durch
solche Kontrollen massiv gestört wären
oder sind denn jetzt eben
Grenzkontrollen wie wir sie auch erleben
dann jetzt in zu Österreich sind das
ihre Meinung nach der Schlüssel gegen
schleuserkriminalität
ich glaube eines der Probleme ist dass
diese Debatte sehr unempirisch also ohne
betrachten von dem was in den letzten
zehn Jahren in Europa schon probiert
wurde geführt wird ich gebe Ihnen nur
ein Beispiel österreich hat seit Jahren
Grenzkontrollen zu Ungarn
trotzdem sind im letzten Jahr
sehr sehr viele Menschen aus Ungarn dass
er an der Außengrenze liegt in einem
Zaun gebaut hat schon 2015
unglaublich große Zahlen von Menschen
über die ungarische Grenze nach
Österreich gekommen wurden dort auch
gestoppt haben aber dann in Österreich
einen Asylantrag gestellt mit dem
Ergebnis dass Österreich im letzten Jahr
mit die höchsten pro Kopf die höchsten
asylantragszahlen in der EU hatte trotz
Grenzkontrollen die Schweiz macht keine
Grenzkontrollen die Schweiz hat auch
hohe Zahlen wenn es darum geht wer
Schutz bekommt aber hat um vieles
niedrigere Antragszahlen weil ich
Schweizer klugerweise und ich war
mehrmals im Bern sagen wenn wir Leute
aufgreifen an der
Schweizer Grenze wenn die aus Österreich
kommen wir könnten versuchen die
Österreicher nehmen Sie übrigens auch
gar nicht zurück aber wir könnten
versuchen darüber zu reden dass sie
zurückgeschickt werden nach Österreich
dann probieren Sie es heute eine Woche
später noch einmal und genau das und das
ist vielleicht der letzte entscheidende
Punkt passiert an der französisch-bahn
italienischen Grenze seit November 2015
die Grenzkontrollen von Frankreich an
der Grenze zu Italien wurden schon im
November 2015 eingeführt das war die
Woche der Attentate in Paris sie
erinnern sich vielleicht den Vater klar
in diesem Theater seit November 2015
gibt's da Grenzkontrollen und in den
vier Jahren zeigt die Grenzkontrollen
durch Frankreich eingeführt wurden hat
sich die Zahl der Asylanträge in
Frankreich verdoppelt so dass im Jahr
2019 Frankreich mehr synanträge hatte
als 2015 also die die Lehre aus all dem
ist
stationäre oder temporäre
Grenzkontrollen an quasi offenen Grenzen
denn die grüne Grenze ist zwischen all
diesen Ländern offen es gibt unzählige
Grenzen Übergänge und vor allem kann es
jeder der gestoppt wird unzählige Mal
erneut probieren alle diese Kontrollen
haben die Zahl der Asylanträge weder in
Österreich noch in Frankreich reduziert
und ich bin überzeugt wenn die gesamte
Bundespolizei was tatsächlich eine
Verschwendung dieser kostbaren Ressource
der Beamtinnen und Beamten ist jetzt den
Auftrag bekommen dann allen deutschen
Grenzen solange es Migration gibt zu
kontrollieren die asylantragszahlen in
Deutschland würden nicht zurückgehen
davon bin ich ganz überzeugt weil das in
allen anderen Ländern auch so ist da
steht ihre Aussage jetzt in einem
Kontrast zu zu vielem was hätte es eben
gesagt hat aber die Schilderungen jetzt
auch von den Kollegen vor Ort in Sachsen
das ist ja real die Situation wie sie
sich dort fortfinden lässt die gibt es
ja und offensichtlich da auch eine eine
enorme Überforderung oder eine enorme
Forderung sagen wir auf jeden Fall von
den Menschen die da vor Ort sind was
sollte denn aber dann ihrer Meinung nach
dagegen getan werden
Deutschland und Österreich und die
Schweiz zusammen mit Frankreich sind in
Europa ja weltweit die Länder mit unter
anderem den höchsten Asylanträgen und
das kommt in Deutschland Österreich und
der Schweiz noch zusätzlich zu der
historisch einmalig großen Zahl von
Flüchtlingen die aus der Ukraine im
letzten Jahr aufgenommen wurden also es
stimmt absolut es gibt in Deutschland
heute eine historische seit dem 40er
Jahren einmal die große Zahl von
Menschen die versorgt werden müssen
andere europäische Staaten brechen EU
Recht oder verhalten sich so dass
Menschen einfach weiterziehen da liegt
der Schlüssel für das Problem und der
zweite Schlüssel liegt darin dass es an
den Außengrenzen der Europäischen Union
nicht wirklich gelingt
humane aber effektive Kontrolle
irreguläre Meditation einzuführen
darüber müssen wir reden wie kann man
die irregulär kommenden über die Türkei
nach Griechenland oder Bulgarien die die
sich in die Boote setzen und über das
Mittelmeer kommen oder auch auch die
Zahl der Menschen die ist natürlich viel
kleiner als über das Mittelmeer aber
trotzdem die über Polen aus Belarus
kommen wie kann man dort diese Zahl
reduzieren aber wenn Menschen bereits
einmal im Schengenraum sind dann zeigen
uns alle Erfahrungen dass die Versuche
der Art von Kontrollen die wir derzeit
einführen aufgrund der geringen Zahl der
wärmsten aufgrund der unzähligen
Möglichkeiten und der Möglichkeit ist
immer wieder zu probieren erscheitern
werden also ein Syrer oder ein Afghane
der heute in Tschechien ist
und nach Deutschland will der schafft es
auch aber die Frustration für viele
Beamten ist wenn man den Auftrag gibt
stoppt die Leute und dann machen sie die
Kontrollen und dann stoppen sie Leute
dann können Sie einige auch
zurückschicken manche können Sie
rechtlich gar nicht zurückschicken und
dann tauchen die gleiche Leute eine
Woche später bei einer anderen Kontrolle
wieder auf und dann noch mal eine Woche
später wieder weil was sollen die
Tschechien denn machen die Leute die
Tschechien ankommen haben die
Europäische Union ja nicht in Tschechien
betreten sondern meistens sind sie über
Ungarn gekommen oder bei Griechenland
oder über Rumänien in den Schengen Raum
und Tschechien sagt wir sind auch nicht
zuständig und das Problem ist die Leute
verschwinden nicht weil es gibt von
keinem europäischen Land natürlich
Rückführungen nach Syrien die Leute
bekommen ja in der eu-schutz es gibt von
keinem europäischen Land Rückführungen
nach Afghanistan die sind nicht möglich
es gibt keine Kooperation mit dem
Taliban also die Syrern darf gar nicht
verschwinden ja nicht die lösen sich
nicht den Luft auf und am Ende werden
sie es probieren bis sie in einem Land
sind wo sie human behandelt werden und
da ist das echte Problem dass Länder wie
Ungarn im letzten Jahr überhaupt keine
Asylanträge hatten
am Ende waren es 40 Österreich hatte
über 110.000 Ungarn liegt daran dass
Außengrenze Österreich nicht der Grund
Ungarn hat das Asylrecht im Land einfach
abgeschafft rechtswidrig der europäische
Gericht sofort Ungarn verurteilt die
ungarische Regierung hat gesagt das
Urteil höchsten europäischen Gerichts
ist uns egal bis jetzt gab es keine
Geldstrafe dafür dass der Fall liegt
wieder beim Gericht solange es möglich
ist europäisches Recht auch Kosten
anderer Staaten wie Deutschland einfach
zu ignorieren so lange
fehlt uns die Solidarität und so lange
wird diese Binnenmigration in der EU
weitergehen und die Bundespolizei
ich verstehe die Frustration vollkommen
denn die Polizei kann dieses Problem das
andere geschaffen haben dann nicht lösen
es gibt dazu jetzt Fragen an sie aus dem
Stream von Holger linke der fragt sich
ja mal eben auch Ungarn z.B angesprochen
wie sieht es denn mit dem politischen
Druck auf die Regierung der
Nachbarländer aus wird dort etwas getan
oder das Problem nur weiter geschoben
wir müssen hier unterscheiden also wie
gesagt österreich hat nicht nur pro Kopf
im letzten sondern auch in diesem Jahr
mehr Asylanträge als Deutschland
Österreich hat pro Kopf im letzten Jahr
und in den letzten fünf Jahren und in
diesem Jahr auch mehr positive
Asylentscheidungen getroffen als
Deutschland also in Österreich und in
der Schweiz wo der Rechtsstaat
funktioniert die die dort einen
Asylantrag stellen wollen die die dort
bleiben die wenn sie Schutz brauchen
bekommen Sie ihn diese Länder sind
sozusagen
solidarisch indem Sie sich einfach an
das Recht halten auch in Frankreich wenn
man eine Asylantrag stellt wird der
geprüft und in Frankreich gibt's auch
relativ hohe anerkennungszahlen andere
Länder ich meine ein krasses Beispiel
ist Griechenland selbst diejenigen die
in Griechenland Schutz bekommen
und es sind zehntausende den
Griechenland schon erhalten haben in den
letzten Jahren
sind dann oft weitergezogen nach
Deutschland und haben in Deutschland
einen zweiten Asylantrag gestellt und
die deutschen Gerichte haben dann
entschieden aufgrund der schlechten
Behandlung auch für anerkannte
Flüchtlinge in Griechenland sagen
deutsche Gerichte im Einklang mit
deutschem Recht und der deutschen
Verfassung die Menschenwürde
als den höchsten Wert definiert die
Menschenwürde dieser Menschen wäre
gefährdet wenn man sie nach Griechenland
zurückschickt das ist total
unsolidarisch denn das bedeutet dass
selbst anerkannte Flüchtlinge in einem
anderen EU-Staat anerkannt einfach nach
Deutschland weiterziehen
ähnliche Entscheidungen gab es auch in
der Vergangenheit schon zu Italien also
das Problem ist tatsächlich der Druck
auf Staaten die sich nicht an EU Recht
halten und das Augenzwinkern wenn
Staaten EU Recht brechen
gegen Asylsuchende gegen Flüchtlinge
gegen Migranten da das schadet am Ende
den Staaten wie Deutschland Österreich
Frankreich die Schweiz die sich im
Schengen Raum weiterhin weil das ihre
Verständnis von Recht ist an das Recht
halten lassen Sie uns aber nochmal auf
die ganz konkrete Situation die wir
jetzt ja haben in Sachsen an der Grenze
zurückkommen wir hatten auch am Anfang
der Sendung schon den sächsischen
Innenminister Schuster gehört der
folgendes auch noch dazu gesagt hat wir
sind an den Außengrenzen eben nicht in
der Lage das alles einzudämmen so
Schuster und er sagt auch schenken
funktioniert nicht also das steht ja
jetzt ja auch wieder eine Widerspruch zu
dem was sie gerade gesagt haben er ist
jetzt hier der Meinung es funktioniert
ja offensichtlich nicht was tun also
die Frage ist Schengen ist ja die Idee
von grenzenlosen Reisen also man soll
also die Idee von Schengen ist ja das an
der deutsch-österreichischen oder
deutsch-französischen Grenze so wenig
kontrolliert wird wenn der Grenze
zwischen Brandenburg und Sachsen also
das ist ja die Grundidee darum gibt
haben wir die meisten also alle
europäischen Staaten auch keine
Grenzpolizei um ihre Binnengrenzen zu
kontrollieren das wurde abgebaut das
heißt Schengen das Funktionieren von
Schengen die Idee ist ja dass Menschen
an diesen Binnengrenzen sich so bewegen
können wie an den Grenzen zwischen den
Bundesländern was nicht funktioniert ist
die Durchsetzung des Rechts wenn es um
die Standards bei also Öl geht und was
viel besser funktioniert müsste ist die
Situation an den Außengrenzen in diesem
Jahr ist eine Rekordzahl von Menschen in
zentralen Mittelmeer in Boden in den
letzten sieben Monaten acht Monaten nach
Italien gekommen wobei man sagen muss
die meisten die in diesem Jahr
in großer Zahl schon über 100.000
irregulär über Tunesien oder Libyen nach
Italien kommen nicht nach Deutschland
die Nationalitäten die Italien ankommen
die bleiben entweder in Italien oder
ziehen oft nach Frankreich sie sind oft
Französisch sprachig nach Deutschland
kommen vor allem Syrer Afghanen und und
andere und da ist auch da ist die
vernünftige Diskussion eine über die
Außengrenzen also wer wie kann man es
schaffen dass an der griechisch türkisch
an der bulgarisch türkischen Grenze denn
wenn Leute mal in Südosteuropa sind auf
dem balkern werden sie auch nicht
gestoppt niemand der in den letzten
Jahren seit der sogenannten Schließung
der Balkanroute in Bosnien war und
weiter wollte sitzt heute noch in
Bosnien die Leute werden mit Gewalt an
der kroatischen Grenze zurückgedrängt da
gibt's grauenhaftes Szenen die auch gut
dokumentiert wurden von vielen Medien
von Menschenrechtsorganisationen auch
von EU Institutionen aber trotzdem beim
dritten vierten fünften Mal schaffen es
alle den Balkan zu verlassen die Frage
ist also wirklich ganz konkret was kann
man an der Außengrenze machen haben wir
eine neue Einigung mit der Türkei gibt
es Möglichkeiten Leute zurückzuschicken
wenn sie in Griechenland oder Bulgarien
Ankommen in die Türkei im Einklang mit
unserem gültigen Recht also so dass Sie
in der Türkei auch sicher sind was
bieten wir dafür an darüber müssen wir
nachdenken wir brauchen die
migrationsabkommen um Leute
zurückschicken zu können die irregulär
kommen dazu brauchen wir sichere Länder
die unsere Partner sind und die sie auch
zurücknehmen wollen das muss im Zentrum
der Debatte stehen wenn Leute mal im
Schengen Raum sind wie gesagt alle
Versuche das weiterziehen zu verhindern
sind in den letzten zehn Jahren in allen
Ländern der das probiert haben
gescheitert aber was sagt man jetzt ganz
konkret den Menschen in Sachsen vor Ort
die sich diesem Problem stellen müssen
was ist die Antwort an die Menschen dort
dass die Lösung nicht in Kontrollen
besteht die nicht dazu führen würden
dass weniger Leute kommen die nur zu
Frustration führen bei den Polizisten
die das Probieren fragen Sie die
Kollegen an der französischen
italienischen Grenze dass die Lösung
darin bestehen muss irreguläre Migration
in die EU zu reduzieren und gleichzeitig
den Druck auf die Länder zu erhöhen die
ihren Beitrag durch Rechtsbruch und
Verletzung der Standards nicht erfüllen
und gleich zu sagen die Tschechen zum
Beispiel sind das Land in Europa das im
letzten Jahr pro Kopf die größte Zahl
von Ukrainern aufgenommen hat über
400.000 Ukrainer sind in einem Land mit
10 Millionen Einwohnern aufgenommen
worden also Tschechien leistet einen
unglaublichen Beitrag bei der
Unterstützung von Flüchtlingen und so
gesehen muss man sich wirklich auf die
Länder konzentrieren wie Ungarn zum
Beispiel wo weder ukrainische
Flüchtlinge bedeutet in der Zeit noch
sonst irgendein Asylantragsteller eine
Chance hat Asyl zu stellen und Viktor
Orban verkauft sein Konzept immer wieder
als als Lösung in Wirklichkeit hält sein
Zaun niemand davon ab die Leute ziehen
nur durch Ungarn durch ja und Lampen
dann in Österreich oder Deutschland also
konkret wir brauchen das Debatten über
Dinge die wirklich etwas bewirken
könnten das sind migrationsabkommen an
den Außengrenzen strategische
Rückführungen in sichere Staaten von den
Außengrenzen und mehr Solidarität durch
Durchsetzung des Rechts in der EU nur
dann werden wir die Zahlen der Menschen
die sich nach Deutschland Österreich die
Schweiz nach Frankreich bewegen
reduzieren können als weitere konkrete
Frage die habe ich mehrfach gesehen bei
uns im Stream jetzt zu der Situation an
der Grenze Polen Deutschland warum
werden die illegalen Einreisenden nicht
wieder zum Beispiel nach Polen
zurückgeschickt möchte jemand wissen
also ich gebe Ihnen nur zwei Zahlen im
letzten in den ersten sechs Monaten
dieses Jahres gab es in Polen ungefähr
3.600 Asylanträge
Polen vergibt auch Asyl aber eben vor
allem Menschen aus Belarus die kommen
nach Polen die stellen den Antrag die
bekommen auch aus Öl in Deutschland gab
es in den ersten sechs Monaten dieses
Jahres ich glaube es sind über 150.000
Asylanträge sind jetzt schon über 188
000 sie haben die Zahl genannt also in
Polen sind 2% der Asylanträge in
Deutschland jetzt kann man sagen mit
einer großen Anstrengung vielleicht
durch viele Grenzkontrollen die an den
Straßen möglichst viele Autos überprüfen
die aber natürlich auch die grüne Grenze
kontrollieren müssen wir kämen dann in
eine Situation wie in den 90er Jahren wo
Leute vielleicht in der Nacht versuchen
mit Schiffen über den Fluss zu kommen
damals sind dutzende Menschen ertrunken
könnte man die Zahl der Menschen die in
Polen den Antrag stellen um ein paar
Prozent erhöhen aber eine wirkliche
Lösung des Problems ist es nicht also
man kann Seite nach Polen zurückschicken
aber sie probieren es dann eben ein
zweites drittes viertes Mal das ist das
Problem an an dieser Situation wie
gesagt man kann natürlich Grenzen
sichern man kann Zäune bauen die man
nicht umgehen kann wer so einen Zaun
sehen will der geht an die Grenze von
Israel zu Ägypten oder auch eine Grenze
von Polen nach Belarus da sind hunderte
Kilometer Zaun gebaut worden mit Militär
nur wer in Deutschland will so eine
Grenze rund um Deutschland bauen also
eine unüberwindbare Mauer die an die
Berliner Mauer erinnert mit Gräben und
Kontrollen und Drohnen es gibt diese
Vorschläge von einigen Professoren die
AFD hat sie aufgegriffen aber ich glaube
die große Mehrheit der Deutschen
sieht darin eine Dystopie also eine
absurde Vorstellung dass sich
Deutschland jetzt wirklich zu einer
Festung einbaut und die pragmatischen
Schweizer haben erkannt dass das nichts
bringt und selbst in der
flüchtlingskrise 15 2 16 und seitdem
haben die Schweizer
nicht darüber nachgedacht obwohl sie
eine große
konservative Partei haben die die
Schweizer Volkspartei haben sie die
Profis die Polizei in der Schweiz nicht
darüber nachgedacht jetzt an den
Schweizer Grenzen die Menschen daran zu
hindern die Schweiz zu betreten weil der
Aufwand nicht mit dem Ergebnis
zusammenpasst und ja es ziehen Leute
auch aus der Schweiz weiter nach
Deutschland aber die Schweiz gibt auch
Asyl diese Grenzkontrollen hat man nur
erkannt reduzieren die Zahl der Menschen
die die Schweiz betreten nicht wirklich
vielleicht zum Ende dass wir konstruktiv
malenden mal an sie gefragt ne
Zukunftsvision eine Zukunftsperspektive
sehen sie irgendwo einen Ansatz der
funktionieren könnte sehen Sie einen
eine Idee für eine einheitliche Position
in Europa wo es vielleicht mal was
konstruktives wo wir hinschauen können
wo funktioniert gut was funktioniert gut
absolut also ein paar ganz konstruktive
Vorschläge erstens was die Ukraine
betrifft darüber reden wir weniger das
zum Glück gibt es da auch noch eine
breite Unterstützung aber wenn mehr
Ukrainer jetzt im kommenden Winter
wieder kämen wenn die Russen die die
Energieversorgung zerstören es ist
bemerkenswert manche europäische Länder
haben sehr wenige aufgenommen weil sie
wenig Leistungen bieten vor allem für
das Wohnen Das sollte man rechtzeitig
angehen Solidarität auch bei der
Aufnahme der größten Zahl von
Flüchtlingen in Europa das würde
Deutschland aber eben auch Polen und
Tschechien entlasten darüber könnte man
sofort reden wenn die Beschluss dass es
diese Solidarität geben soll zumindest
finanzielle Kompensation den hat die EU
schon getroffen sie setzt ihn nur nicht
um zweitens wir brauchen an den
Außengrenzen müssen es schaffen die Zahl
der irregulär kommenden oder noch sehr
sehr viele sterben zu reduzieren
Koalitionsvertrag ist da sehr klar man
braucht migrationsabkommen man braucht
Rückführungen im Einklang mit dem EU
Recht braucht man aber Partner die auch
sicher sind dass man Leute
zurückschicken kann
da müsste da dem Senegal Angebote machen
oder Gambia Marokko man müsste wieder
mit der Türkei diskutieren das ist gehen
kann durch migrationsabkommen irreguläre
Migration zu reduzieren haben wir 2016
gesehen da ist die Zahl die aus der
Türkei nach Griechenland kam von einer
Millionen 12 Wochen 12 Monaten auf
26.000 in den 12 Monaten danach gefallen
durch ein Abkommen drittens brauchen wir
auch eine Diskussion über sichere
Drittstaaten wenn ein Land uns erpressen
will die Belarus und Leute extra nach
Belarus gelockt werden um über Belarus
nach Polen und natürlich vor allem nach
Deutschland zu kommen dann wäre die
Antwort die rechtsstaatliche Antwort zu
sagen die Leute werden nicht in den
Urwald zurückgedrängt sie werden nicht
alle Grenze verprügelt sie werden nicht
im Gegensatz zum EU-Recht daran
gehindert einen Asylantrag zu stellen
aber wer da kommt wir machen eine
Einigung mit einem sicheren Drittstaat
wo die Leute dann hingebracht würden
aber einem sticht kaputt das Ziel ist
diese Leute davon zu entmutigen
Schlepper zu bezahlen und nach Belarus
zu gehen dazu brauchen wir Drittstaaten
mit denen wir darüber verhandeln
Angebote zu machen die Koalition hat das
in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag als
Möglichkeit eröffnet sie sagt in
Notfällen und um Erpressung vorzubeugen
soll man auch mit Drittstaaten reden um
dort die Asylverfahren durchzuführen das
steht im Koalitionsvertrag aller drei
Parteien man hat es bis jetzt allerdings
nicht nur nicht durchgesetzt sondern in
Brüssel darüber geredet dass man das
eigentlich auf europäischer Ebene
unmöglich machen will das ist ein
Widerspruch das muss man auflösen und
ich glaube mit konkreten Dingen die die
Verantwortung für die große Zahl der
Ukraine die
Maßnahmen einen Außengrenzen die
irreguläre Migration reduzieren und auch
Konzepte mit sicheren Drittstaaten
zusammenbringen hätte man echt einen
Effekt und das würden dann auch die
deutschen Kommunen
das was wir derzeit machen ist leider
eine Debatte die sich im Kreis dreht und
ich glaube die Frustration der
Bundespolizisten wird eher noch wachsen
auch wenn man ihnen jetzt sagt wir
schicken euch an die technische Grenze
denn spätestens wenn die gleichen
Personen drei vier Mal aufgegriffen
werden werden Sie erkennen französischen
Kollegen an der Grenze wenn die milia
Italien das dass sie hier eigentlich ja
Statisten sind in einem absurden Theater
die Einschätzung von Migrationsforscher
Gerald Knaus vielen Dank dass Sie heute
bei uns zu Gast waren ich danke Ihnen
die Sendung ist jetzt hier mit am Ende
aber ihr könnt sehr gerne noch weiter
sachlich im Chat diskutieren euch
austauschen das muss nicht zu Ende sein
nur wir sagen für jetzt für heute alle
aus dem gesamten Team vielen Dank gerne
bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss